I think you are good with, uh...
[drum Rolls]
People.
Why is it taking you so long?
[Ray laughs]
(playful jazz music)
The Big Sick.
I'm a stand-up comedian, I fall
in love with a white woman,
she gets sick, and then you're--
I'm her father.
Yeah, and you come and
visit and we hang out.
I think if I give Ray a compliment,
you're very good at turning it around
and making it--
[Ray] A negative?
Yeah.
I personally am not good at taking--
[Kumail] Me neither.
Or giving.
But we can try giving compliments.
I like your glasses.
I don't like shoes, but those don't suck.
You don't like shoes?
My wife Emily, any time she sees the movie
keeps talking about how handsome you are.
I really don't, I feel mixed about it.
Are you mixed about it because
you're a little jealous,
or are you mixed about it because,
"If she thinks he's handsome..."
[Kumail laughs]
Your kids are all very nice
and, like, good people,
and, like, grounded.
Thank you very much, but also,
my kids told me to do this movie
when they heard you were in it.
I saw edits of the movie before he did,
so I would just text him and
tell him how funny he was
in the movie.
Usually also when I text you about
how insecure I am about something,
like, "Oh, like they're
gonna hate me in this,"
you would text back,
"Someone with your talent
is that insecure."
So it was like a--
It was actually inspiring.
Therapeutic.
- Oh yeah?
- It was therapeutic.
Yeah.
Because I'm not good at it,
and it's also good that, you know,
we truly do respect and like each other.
I felt kind of awkward because
I really, really like Ray,
and we text each other
nice stuff about each other
all the time,
but doing it face to face while he's here
and me telling him, "I think
your eyes are so soulful--"
It's awkward.
[laughs] Yeah, that's the word.
The erection threw me.
It's a nervous erection, calm down.
[Ray laughs]
This happens whenever I
don't know what to do.
See The Big Sick everywhere July 14th.